are men looking for leadership
you guys weigh in when you want
um
I would say that there's an attack on
truth
and I think men favor truth as opposed
to opinion so it's not necessarily
attack on masculinity it's attack on
truth and because you're attacking truth
you're leaning towards the side of men
um
so yeah that's what I would say is more
of so like she said like give an example
of like lizard or like finding hot
chicks men know like oh I'll fight so if
you try to convince me to find this
attractive or whatever it may be you
were like no
well if you told so if you if you give
me the truth men will just just go lean
towards that side that's what I think is
more of
so yeah okay
you said you agree with what he said
I just feel like I agree with you saying
that they
agree with truth but
she threw me off with the lizzo and the
um
what other statement did she say with
the heart like you know she threw me off
with the lizard statement because I just
feel like in society today obviously as
being a big girl myself I just feel like
is your opinion if you like big girls or
not and it doesn't matter if you don't
like big girls is your opinion at the
end of the day and I do feel like
Society is trying to stretch it to say
oh if you don't like big people you're
problematic but it's just it's just down
to preference at the end of the day and
that's just how I feel so just me being
a big girl like I don't really care if a
guy says he doesn't like big girls okay
that's your opinion I don't like big
guys I mean why why do you feel like
you're So based with that because that's
not common what do you mean like a lot
of girls that are bigger like they get
offended I don't get offended and and I
don't either like if a guy said I don't
like tall gingers I'd be like okay yeah
I just feel like society today we're all
like about be kind we're all about like
pro pro big girls with about Pro like
just a lot of things that is just if
it's an opinion as an opinion but we're
just pushing it way too much to the
point where she's sending an example of
um Andrew Tate because I've watched his
Clips like promoting leadership but at
the end of the day I'm cultured as well
to be honest so I feel like a man should
be a leader it shouldn't be an issue but
maybe the way he's expressing it is just
a problem I mean it's not really like
you being a leader you can be a leader
the facts he's just saying a bit too
much maybe that's why this may be like
the internet today is getting offended
by it the way he speaks about it you
know I don't know me personally I don't
get offended by anything like I know how
I am and that's just how it is what do
you think Troy attack on masculinity I
think it's become increasingly difficult
to talk about certain things relating to
masculinity I mean I work as a primarily
as a dating coach we we teach guys how
to you know become better in the dating
Marketplace we actually work with guys
in real life and um do stuff obviously
online you know over zoom and stuff like
that as well but actually working with
guys in the in the field
getting them into social interactions
watching what they do critiquing what
they do giving them giving them tips on
how to you know how to improve and so on
and um I've often felt that being a
dating coach in 2022 going into 2023 is
one of the most despised jobs in the
entire world because you get Flack from
from what she's talking about you get
flagged from the sort of mainstream
because they will think you're
misogynistic for some reason although
they'll think that you you hate women or
you're being sort of manipulative which
isn't true you'll also get Flack from
the sort of the traditionalists who are
more like well you know you just want to
just bet all these different women and
you're not about a serious serious
relationship stuff like that and that's
not true either necessarily because he's
down to the individual what they want to
do
um so so yeah I think we have got to a
place now where
it's very hard to say anything yeah
because of this culture of everybody
being offended by everything and I think
that's so yeah I think in that and and
you know
feminists would argue well be to redress
the balance from things in the past now
you know we're now sort of men are now
under a lot more scrutiny than they once
were but it seems to me the pendulum has
swung too far in the sense that now we
can't really have a sort of an even
honest conversation about the way things
actually are you know and I don't even
really think that the pendulum was
necessarily for women throughout all of
history because we didn't even have to
fight in worse no we never had to do
that yeah yeah no I know what I was
saying that I was thinking I know you're
you know because I'm not saying that was
necessarily true but I'm just saying
that's what the percentage you know I'm
agreeing with you yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's what that's what the perception
was wasn't it and why why do you think
um
because it's interesting because I was
telling you before the show like I've
been to like a like a dating coach type
conference before and I really didn't
see the big deal like why people were so
mad about it because I'm like if guys
don't know how to talk to women like
isn't it good that we like learn that
they learn we want guys that know how to
talk to us right yeah well you would you
would think so wouldn't you and I've
never really understood the sort of the
height and then and then you get hate
from other people like the doomers who
say well it's all about look so if
you're not six foot seven and you know
you've got a 12 pack and all the rest of
it then you haven't got a chance anyway
so it's all it's all nonsense
um yeah you would think that wouldn't
you because actually all we're doing
really a lot of this stuff it really
goes back to old-fashioned social skills
and old-fashioned confidence skills and
a lot of guys you know people watching
this they might think well this this
game stuff you know this dating advice
stuff it's been around for ages we all
know all this but there's a lot of guys
out there who really really need help
you know they're just really not very
socially Adept and and that's probably
the majority of men yeah I would say you
think so well I think I think the
majority of men are kind of maladapted
to you know social situations sexual
situations relationship situations we
can we we cite the stat you know one in
three men you know for the whole year
has not had sex or yeah right so you
have to understand that a lot of a lot
of men the average man is not socially
adapted to yeah you know interacting
with women generally yeah yeah for sure
and it's only got worse because of the
prevailing culture where now
I mean I've heard some terrible stories
about you you know I'm glad I'm not 18
anymore going into this dating Market
because you know it's like what can you
say what can you not say are you gonna
get accused of some you know some
terrible crime because you asked out the
wrong girl I mean it's it's it's very
long time yes you said the wrong thing
exactly exactly so it's very fraught
with difficulty now and that's the whole
thing about mass for me the attack on
masculinity because
masculine men are quite
they're Hunters I would say right yeah
and when masculine men see a woman that
they like they normally go for it yeah
now that woman I think in the in these
days and times has been kind of
pre-programmed with he shouldn't say
this he shouldn't say that he's not
allowed to make you feel this
uncomfortable right yeah but masculine
men just go for what they go for and
they say what they say but that is now
um a thing where now you know a lot of
women can say oh I felt uncomfortable
and I was actually harassed or you know
so I think Master when I say the attack
there's a girl in the show that said
that she was
um sexually harassed like something she
I forgot what she said she was sexually
assaulted or harassed something like
that yeah and I persistent or something
yeah because some guy was like cat
calling her and like was being
persistent with it I saw that I'm like
are you you're scarred by that
by being cat called if that's the worst
thing that's ever happened to you you've
been had a very privileged life
because because a man called You
Beautiful more than once yeah yeah how
dare you
but that's the thing
like there's a whole group of homeless
people that I walk by here every day
thank you
then you see those articles don't you
where you've got the the female
journalist who is now over the age of
likes that you're 40 or whatever and
she's like oh that guy's not looking at
me anymore and I'm funny hard to adjust
to this new reality where I'm invisible
and it's like well which did you want
you know well that's the thing I think
sorry gone no I was gonna say I
understand what you're saying is an
attack of masculinity and the reason why
I say it's an attack on Truth more than
masculinity is because when
these group of people attack masculinity
they tend to attack femininity as well
and they put it in a position where it's
they're trying to make feminine women
more masculine so I feel like they're
attacking both sides with lies so for
example in the case of like oh when you
get to making women feel like oh when
you thought you're going to be desirable
and all of this kind of thing that's
just not the truth like okay it works
for some people so they're attacking the
truth more
and we if you if he align with the truth
more you you tend to be like I I
generally believe men align with facts
more like less of their feelings more
facts no because when women speak they
say I feel like and that's obviously a
fact
I agree because like the reason why I
was just being Physicians because the
show that's what we hear all the time
like I feel like right but
when you say there is an attack on
femininity also so I agree that the
society in which we live in is
attempting to effeminize men and then
masculine lives women right and so I
think that's one of the major reasons
why so many podcast shows are the way
they are talking about relationships
because I think that men and women have
lost their role so yeah while I would
say there is an attack on masculinity
yes right I think there's an attack on
femininity also trying to make them more
masculine yeah I would second that I
remember
um it was a clip of Bishop TD Jakes from
the states he said like in his church
um that women need to stop asking acting
so masculine and start being feminine I
saw it and I was like I'm surprised he's
saying that in the church but there was
so much backlash from it I'm like if
y'all just shut up and listen to what
he's saying like it's uh huh the women
shopping list everybody but more so
women
yeah what do you guys mean by them being
less masculine though because I thought
no women like we should stop being more
like less masculine or whatever because
I just feel like they're talking about
independence like I mean like we're more
able to do our own stuff without the
men's yeah but men don't want that they
want to be needed like when you say I
don't need a man like the guys want to
run but that's not really that's not
that to me that's not really a masculine
I would you wouldn't say like
Independence yeah yeah I would say that
that's masculine
like feminine feminine like throughout
all of history we needed Ben right we
still need men we just don't admit it
like men built the world for us we
couldn't we couldn't survive without
without them they do the plumbing the
the sewers the garbage collection as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible